hey everyone how's it going persia here
and i am back
to feature another new set in animal
crossing new horizons
the summer updates are underway and we
already know that gullibar
and pascal have joined the roster of
special characters in part one
of the summer updates and if you missed
the
goal of our set video that we did before
then
go ahead and check that out but now we
are going to feature pascal's set
which is all the mermaid items
so as you can see we have a bunch of
furniture items these are all diys
unlike all of our set where he just gave
you the items straight up
to get these items you just have to go
deep sea diving
also part of the new update and you'll
find a scallop and pascal will pop up
sometimes he pops up on the first
scallop that you catch sometimes he pops
up on the third or fourth scallop that
you catch
but at least once a day pascal will show
up to
ask if you want to trade your scallop
for a special item
being one of these but today we're just
gonna feature
some of these awesome furniture items we
have a vanity
we have a closet a lamp a screen a shelf
a wall clock
a lot of different things so let's just
check out the furniture first
and as i'm showing off the items we're
gonna put screenshots up so you can
actually see what each
diy recipe calls for so make sure you're
paying attention
to those recipes while we're featuring
the furniture
all right so here are all of the
furniture items
and one thing to keep in mind these are
not customizable
so what you see is what she again right
in the middle we have this very adorable
star rug starfish rug not sure i
personally love the color scheme of this
set
we have the mermaid bed super cute
i love that the pillows are little
fishies
little fishy pillows very cute
the detail on these items are really
cute especially with the
like rainbow pearl scheme that we've got
going
like on the foot part and the headrest
next to that we also have the the chair
the mermaid chair same print same style
of course
then we also have the standing lamp that
you can turn on
and off we also have the
wall clock you can hear it ticking very
cute
and then underneath that is the mermaid
table you can put things on top of there
usually items look best right in the
center you know how some
tables can be where you put it on the
side and have the items hanging off the
ledge so i would recommend putting
things right
in the center the mermaid shelf is
super cute too it has all of these
little bottles
different colors visually striking
like the coral on the sides to kind of
hold up
the second part the mermaid dresser also
has even more of these colorful bottles
the shelves with the seashells as the
door handles
very cute you also have the closet
closet is also very cute
a little more subtle the couch
is probably my favorite item of the
entire set
i love the little pillows i love that
it's a little asymmetrical
if you sit on this side it's very cute
you can show off the pillows or you can
move over to the other side and just
live that life of luxury and be
surrounded by the cushions i love it
vanity is also super cute in my room i
have the mermaid chair right in front of
it it matches really well
just the overall shape and silhouette
around the mirror
mixed with the chair looks really really
good it's very cute got the little
powder brush on there
little perfume bottles
and then we have the screen
another one of my favorite items just
because i think it looks really elegant
really elegant really cute it has a
little fish swimming pattern
which i think is a nice detail
considering
that the print on the chairs and the bed
are like seashells like the floor of the
sea whereas the screen is standing up
and it's kind of reflecting
the water and fish are swimming if that
makes any sense you guys get it you guys
get
i also really love the floor and the
wall obviously the color
scheme is great but the lights when you
turn it off it actually glows
this really nice relaxing hue of pink
obviously you have the bubbles floating
up to the top
very peaceful very cute love the energy
and
you can also see the light turn on and
off here i couldn't feature it before
pascal also gives out some very cute
dresses
some very cute shoes and this really
adorable tiara
all of them obviously fit the whole
theme of the mermaid set
my personal favorite is the one that i
have on right now i really really like
the color scheme with the blue and the
pink
i did like the pirate dresses from the
gulliver set but i would have to say
these are definitely more my styles so
thank you pascal all of them
match pretty well with the tiara so
that's pretty much a no-brainer you
could just
put the tiara on and be a-okay but
here's what some of the other dresses
look like i also have the mermaid shoes
on
the pink one is very cute too i
personally like this silhouette a little
bit more for my character
but yeah this color scheme right here
this is my favorite what do you guys
think
let's go ahead and take a closer look at
the shoes too we got the blue
and the pink shoes even though you can't
see them at all
because of this dress but as you can
tell very much
fitting with the theme i always enjoy a
matching shoe
i definitely want to do another giveaway
so if you guys
comment down below what your favorite
mermaid item is you could win
the entire furniture set let me know
what you're hoping to see
in the next summer update and make sure
you're keeping an eye on your comment if
you're submitting for the giveaway
because i respond
directly to your comment if you win so
thank you guys so much
make sure you stay tuned to gamespot for
more animal crossing new horizons
goodness and i will see you guys next
time peace out
you